russell wilson uh we just saw him
basically lobbying for the seahawks to
sign antonio and give him another chance
what were your thoughts on that slash
double barrel question
slash did anything dr johnson just said
about the potential signing
change your mind because yesterday you
you were pretty adamant that you thought
the seahawks
would get that last infinity stone by
adding antonio brown
no he didn't change my mind uh he didn't
change my mind i still think
antonio brown will help this team and
hearing russell yesterday
even uh you know further solidified the
way i feel about it look
i think dr johnson brings up a great
point and she usually does but i think
he brings up a great point
about antonio brown accepting some of
the things that he's done
because he has always been a guy who is
now who has not taken responsibility for
his actions
sound familiar every time something goes
wrong he's got somebody else to blame
and the guy to blame is the guy in the
mirror so
that is something he's got to do and if
he's willing to do that now that's a big
step
and he probably has done that privately
already otherwise
he wouldn't be he wouldn't even be in
this conversation
because i think to get to be reinstated
by roger goodell i think he's gonna have
to go to the commissioner and say
yeah i take responsibility for what i've
done
but to really have some credibility in
that locker room he's gonna have to say
in the locker room and publicly i did
some things wrong
and i'm sorry even if he doesn't mean it
let's just be realistic some people say
it don't mean it
but if he does that we're talking about
the assault
that he's being investigated correct
that's what we're talking about right
we're talking about he has no i think
we're talking about a lot of things
antonio brown you can be talking about
many things
okay well that what see i'm talking
about from a football and a football
culture sense let's talk about though
the
the sexual assault allegations uh and
the other legal issues that he has going
on
that might require several league more
league discipline
i can't even keep track but let's yeah
let's talk about that in particular
i've always struggled over the course of
my career
whether it's domestic violence
dog fighting dui
you name it with
trying to assign the perfect number for
punishment
it always bothered me actually you know
like the common question
you know for somebody when it came to
personal conduct was
did the league get it right i mean like
what's right like what's right what's
right for
for a criminal offense what's right for
domestic violence regardless of how the
criminal justice system handle it what's
right for dog
like what's what's right like how can
anybody say that
or six games is what you should get for
hitting a woman or you know
four games what you should get for a dui
it's like are they coming back if
they're coming back
does it really matter at the end of the
day if they eventually gonna come back
because they're good enough
at the end of the day they come in they
get another chance because they're good
enough
what's the difference in six games and
eight games does it make it
like unbelievable the crime it doesn't
yeah please be my guest
can i answer that question for you
enlighten me it's not necessarily the
games you're right
all right the game six games eight games
two game four games
but there's a difference between say a
ray rice
who did what he did goes to a diversion
program
then when the video came out the nfl
said oh wait a minute uh this looks bad
even though everything that was in that
video
was described in a police report
it was in a police report so it tells
you just how limited we are
at times it the written word it's right
there
but when we see the video it changes
everything but that's that's not no i
feel it no i [ __ ]
i fully understand that okay okay go
ahead but ray rice but at least okay
ray rice what he did unconscionable
unthinkable
and you can have your feelings about his
wife
uh now but at the time his fiancee
taking him back
and his and her parents being there at
that press conference in baltimore
her dad sitting there in the front row
think about it mike i mean it's just
difficult
your daughter's being
hit by anybody but being hit
by a man and you're sitting there in the
front row saying
okay we're family oh that's hard for me
to just even think about
but ray rice has continually said
i own it i'm going to do something about
it i want to go i want to talk to other
people about it his wife has been with
them saying
okay we are fine we're together
he has accepted it and you don't have to
like it but he's accepted it so there is
there is a change in ray rice now some
people don't believe that you could ever
change once you hit a woman they say
that's it
some people believe there can have you
can never change as opposed to
let's go let's be real as opposed to
tyreek hill
who many of you have on your fantasy
football teams who many of you have
forgotten about
tyreek hill still hasn't taken
responsibility
for what he did in college
and just because he's a super bowl champ
just because you think the kansas city
chiefs
are dope with their offense doesn't mean
that he has
accepted responsibility we have just
stopped talking about it so the
difference
is accepting it and not
no that's not the it wasn't respectfully
respectful i appreciate your passion
that wasn't what i was getting
that's not the point that's not what i'm
saying oh no i'm upset but i'm sorry i
didn't say that
that's a good one you're saying don't
have the difference for you i'm sorry
we're not going to talk we're not going
to talk about domestic violence
no no you ain't got to agree
i'm not you're addressing something that
i was never going down that rabbit hole
i said respectfully that wasn't like no
disrespect but his disrespect
i said respectfully i was not going down
i was not i was not comparing the merits
of one domestic violence case to another
that's not the rabbit hole i was going
down i don't want to get off track is
what i'm trying to say
what i'm saying is it's not about
somebody's rehabilitation
we you and i both know it's about if
somebody's
good enough if somebody is good enough
they are worthy of a second chance it's
not about what ray rice did
it's about the fact that ray rice was a
declining running back that's why he
never got another chance
mike we've been there plenty of we
agreed so so but so that's not what
just before you hold on hold on
we agree on that what i'm saying you
asked me you said you've always this is
what you said
you've always struggled with two how
many games is it right isn't that what
you said
i'm saying that the conversation around
the
what suspension how long somebody should
be suspended for criminal acts
to me is the wrong conversation
because whether it's two four six
eight whatever factors you want to
assign to the decision
whether it's how they owned it how they
what what they what kind of diversion
program they entered how their
significant others handled it
it doesn't undo what they did and it's
not going to make everybody happy
ray rice being suspended or anybody
being spending for four games versus six
games
doesn't make a difference in terms of
what they did what i'm saying is the
second chances
i'm talking about the idea of second
chances strictly second chances
always comes down to second third fourth
fifth chances
always comes down to how good somebody
is at football
because antonio brown could say and do
all the right things right now
he can say and do all the things right
things right now and people would still
want to give him a second chance because
they still think he can play the
patriots did it the raiders did it
doesn't matter
my overall point though is i i i'm
you know i'm sorry that i maybe i
distracted from the conversation i
wasn't trying to go there what i'm
saying is
for me and antonio brown and the fit in
seattle
has nothing to do with his transgression
okay with it with off the field
transgression
it has to do with from a football
culture standpoint
okay whether it was with the patriots or
whether it's with the steelers
or whether it's with the raiders in
between antonio doesn't know how to act
we were off camera
before uh the show started you were
as we loved to do you were quoting kings
of comedy
you were quoting cedric entertainer you
know he like anthony mason you can't
take him nowhere
you can't take antonio brown nowhere
and for me if i'm seattle and
specifically russell wilson and that's
why i say russell wilson got to be
careful
because antonio brown of course is going
to say and do
all the right things right now he's
going to say and do all the right things
specifically around russell wilson
he's going to look a lot different in
the context of off-season workouts or
whatever conversation you had
and russell wilson will tell you he
didn't he hadn't investigated all the
things that happened because
players just like teams they don't care
about what happened in pittsburgh or
oakland
or at the time or um or new england all
they care about is
oh my goodness i can get i could throw
the russell i control antonio brown
right now
they don't understand i don't think
would respectfully is that word again
respectfully i don't think russell
wilson understands what he'd be inviting
into his locker room
from a football standpoint from a
football standpoint so all
so the reason i brought up the
suspension and the reason i brought up
the off the field
stuff is simply to say i am not i don't
pretend to be the arbiter
of how long somebody should be suspended
for a specific off the field
transgression
be it 6 8 12 a year
whatever i i'm not and i've never wanted
to say that somebody doesn't deserve a
second chance
at employment but if i were seattle if i
were russell wilson or frankly any other
team
i would look at what antonio brown has
done from a football
standpoint in terms of why the steelers
decided to get rid of him for a fourth
round pick
why the raiders why he blew it up with
the raiders
and while the patriots was like you know
what enough is enough and it wasn't all
to your point earlier it wasn't all
about
the allegations or the accusations or
the investigations
it wasn't all about that it was about
you can't take him nowhere
floor is yours i just want to clarify
yeah what no no
no but no i listen to you very closely
what you said
and i think we agree on
90 of things so
so we we may have gotten to our points
in our conversation at different times
but if you just take what you said and
take what i said we we match up even if
i didn't say it i agree with 90
of what you said absolutely i know the
reason
ray rice is not in the league and the
reason tyreek hill
is in the league is because one was
deemed to be
just done as a football player his
talent wasn't seemed to be
seen to be on the same level as tyree
kills for example so it's all about
the position it's all about talent the
football team says how can you help me
yeah where i think the disagreement and
let me add one more thing before i get
to the
what the disagreement is um
so two two game yes you know should be
two games four games six games
what i think i think it should be based
on
whether it's two games or eight games i
think
you should display some type of remorse
you should just you should display that
you actually get it
and so some people will never get it
some people will get it after a game
like you can suspend them for a game and
they get it immediately you can suspend
them for 10 games and they still don't
get it
but this is where we disagree i think
football culture
you say football not transgressions i
think football culture and
transgressions are connected
so i don't separate them into different
categories
the reason based on what you're saying
the reason antonio brown
will not be a good fit in seattle is
because
antonio brown doesn't have
the capacity to look at himself and say
i've got to change so that is a factor
when it comes to his transgressions
and that is a factor when he goes into a
locker room they're not separate
yeah i i don't believe in comparison
consistency as a whole person
he's got to figure it out and if you're
saying he
if you're saying he hasn't figured it
out uh
if he has and i don't know that away
from the field i don't and i don't know
that i don't know that look
russell wilson russell wilson has talked
to antonio brown a lot more than i have
i don't know antonio brown and again and
and i know what we both agree on as we
both
agree that people you know the idea of
deserving a second chance
as if it's as if we are the ju if we are
enjoy standing in judgment of them and
we get to determine whether or not
you know their sins you know have have
excluded them from the opportunity to
continue to
to pursue a livelihood like that's what
i'm getting at it's like i'm not here to
say whether he's a changed man and
whether he's
met a certain standard to to merit
playing
this is a meritocracy and if you can
play at a certain level you're gonna get
that second chance so it's a moot point
anyway
so i don't know if he's matured i'm
saying
i'm not finding out if i'm running an
organization
i'm not finding out yes there are
certain organizations that
uh can handle those types of players
better than others
one of the pittsburgh steelers one of
the new england patriots
you know so two of the premier
organizations in the league
couldn't contain this guy and all i'm
saying is he's not going there to mentor
tyler lockett and d.k metcalf like so
yeah
of course he looks of course he's you
know straightening up and flying right
and being humbled in the presence of
russell wilson because he want a job
but if he gets there and the rubber
meets the road he's not getting the ball
how's he gonna act
same way he acted in pittsburgh same way
he actually that's why
he got the ball a lot in new england but
i i just don't think i don't think i
have a hard time believing that he's
changed
i need to see it to believe it i'll i'll
see it from afar if i if i'm
if i'm a decision maker in an
organization and i think russell wilson
is standing up for him because
basically what he's doing is vouching
for his character
he's vouching for uh honestly
i think russell wilson's being a good
cardinal brown is right now i think
russell wants to be a good christian
i i mean russell i think russell wilson
in his statement i think he's being a
good christian
i honestly believe that that's what he
was doing yesterday i think he i think
that was
and i don't mean to to to mock of course
i wouldn't mock christianity i am one
but
i didn't receive it that way at all no
but no no but what i'm about to say
i think that was on brand for russell
wilson i think that was very much on
brand
i think that i think russell wilson go
hawks is
a nice guy and is going to say the right
thing about everybody all the time
so he's been around antonio brown from
what he knows of antonio brown
he's impressed with antonio brown and
when you ask him he's never going to say
anything other than the right thing and
so i think that was russell wilson being
russell wilson yesterday
not thinking about the downside he's
strictly trying to see the good in
somebody which maybe we could all take a
lesson from that maybe i could take a
lesson from that trying to see the good
in somebody
and saying yeah he's a good football
player but also i think everybody's
deserving of a second chance and
yeah i get it and that's i'd be
commenting i think you could say
i think you could say nice things about
antonio brown
without also campaigning this was a
campaign
uh for russell wilson russ cooks and
russ campaign this was campaigning
so the the the christian side of him can
say
man you know we're all redeemable and
let's not give up on anybody i wish him
all the best i've talked to him a few
times i wish him all the best
and then you stop so
but he didn't stop he kept going is he
thinking about that i think he's
thinking about a hall of fame
talent that's what he's thinking about
how do you think one thing about a hall
of fame in town
here's here's the great thing about
seattle
they have now it's been a while since
they won the super bowl what 2013
so but they're successful they're
undefeated
if you bring in antonio brown and he's
not on board
you could cut him and keep moving and
your season will be fine and i think
your leverage is
you've been successful without them
antonio brown
his his uh the thing that keeps him in
line is
all right they were fine without me and
if i don't get it right this time
i was cut i asked to be cut from the
raiders
so that didn't mean anything to me i
really wanted to stay with tom brady
and the patriots yeah and they cut me
because i couldn't control myself all he
had to do really i
and this is back to what i was saying
mike about the hypocrisy of the nfl
and and how brutal the league can be at
times
in this october uh domestic violence
awareness month you know
the league they don't care
they don't care if you're not if you've
got
an issue out there and the nfl if the
nfl has dealt with the issue
yet the issue is not resolved all you
got to do is shut up and be quiet and
then it will never come up again
antonio brown right antonio brown got in
trouble
because he was texting
he was texting a woman threatening
bringing her kids in yeah
yeah bringing her kids and the patriots
said move on but if
if that case is out there that case is
unresolved right now right
the one you brought up it still has not
been resolved
right he's being investigated
he still would be on the patriots if he
hadn't texted so
that's my point like he's not
necessarily why don't he go
into it goes back to the video
the ray right situation was cool until
we saw the video so you're absolutely
right it's like it's it's our level of
outrage the nfl has never been proactive
they're reactive to this i will say this
on behalf of antonio brown if anything
is going to humble him
if anything is going to humble him see
because if you think about it all right
pittsburgh traded him
he got his money from the raiders i
still don't know what happened there
but he got out and he got with the
patriots
losing that gig and then being out of
football this long
if anything will be a wake-up call it'd
be that so
this is the la it stands to reason that
they got his attention you know that god
or the football guys whoever
got his attention now at 32 years old
when you know that you are running out
of chances regardless if a successful
team or a successful football culture
brings you a board like you're talking
about in seattle
regardless wherever he ends up going he
got to know
i'm running out of teams not too many
more opportunities
this may be my last one so if anything
will humble you it's that fact
that reality and and i i i will say you
know before he
ran into his uh his problems
and i i know there are a lot of great
wide receivers in the nfl and deandre
hopkins is on that list i know michael
thomas is having some injury issues this
year
uh julio jones keep going down the list
antonio brown's the best receiver in
football when he's right
when he's right let me tell you but let
me tell you something about that let me
tell you something about
that that title what does that even mean
because
let's let's look at the pittsburgh
steelers
i was one of the people again not
knowing how much they were putting up
with although i always suspected he was
the type of person that
cared more about his numbers because if
you go back and look at a lot of
steelers games over the years
whole lot of empty yards whole lot of
empty yards
at the ends of halves and at the ends of
the games going to antonio right though
no he's great
he's great no no i'm not he's great but
i'm just saying
i knew he was a selfish ball player but
there was more to
pittsburgh than then we even met that
met the eye
so when they traded him to the raiders
for i believe it was a fourth round pick
i like many people were like what the
heck are you doing
trading antonio brown for a fourth round
pick are you crazy
pittsburgh because you talked about this
the other day we talked about it
they scout a lot of positions great do
you think they miss antonio brown
do you think they missed antonio brown
well we'll keep in mind
and chase claypool they didn't have a
quarterback they missed their
quarterback last year
i guess what i'm saying is whether like
wide receivers and we're talking about
another one another one who's got a
reputation later in the show
wide receivers no matter how great they
are like
i think we've seen it they they don't
make that much of a difference
or they're not that indispensable in a
league that prioritizes the past the way
that it does
because most people coming into this
season wouldn't have thought that the
seahawks would have loaded that wide
receiver with dk metcalf and tyler
lockett
and david moore right 19 touchdown
passes
best offense in the league highest
scoring offense in the lead so they
don't
need the most talented receive in the
nfl
if he's going to come with even the
slightest amount of headaches i agree
with that
if he's got any baggage then you just
move on if you
you give him a shot it it was third and
kicked off thank you
thank you gary it was third and fifth
round picks that they uh that they
traded a third
yeah third got a third for them yeah so
bottom line is not somebody that uh
you know that you should have to
bend over backwards to accommodate but
hey listen if he comes in and
he's comfortable with the ball going
entirely lock it if he's comfortable
with the ball going to d.k metcalf he's
comfortable the ball going to will
dizzley or
you know russell okay great i
i just i'm just not so sure about that
i'm just not so sure about that part of
it that part that he's just gonna come
in and be a good soldier so
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest
news and highlights from nbc sports